one of the first big people who were way
ahead of me in business that I was able
to come in contact with you either have
to buy your wayd and pay an egregious
amount of money where it actually makes
sense for them but if you're poor that's
tough to do because they're way
wealthier than you and probably don't
want to sell their time I've offered
some people like their speaking fee
times two just to hop on the phone with
me and sometimes it's like $250,000 for
like 1 hour but just to show you what
I'm willing to do to have somebody who
sees the world more clearly than I do
speak into my life because the people
who make more money than you have a more
accurate view of reality